today President Trump will try to press
the reset button and change the
narrative as he addresses supporters
just outside of Washington during the
annual Conservative Political Action
Conference it comes as new questions are
raised about how White House adviser and
presidential son-in-law Jared Kushner
was granted top security clearance
despite objections from the intelligence
community and as mr. Trump draws
criticism for remarks about otto
warmbier the american college student
detained in North Korea who died shortly
after coming home in a coma
Errol Barnett is at the White House this
morning Errol good morning good morning
president Trump returned from that
failed summit with North Korea's leader
by trying to sell it as a success but
this weekend begins with multiple
controversy surrounding the
administration with one involving a
president's son-in-law White House
senior advisor Jared Kushner's top
security clearance was reportedly
obtained only after President Trump
overruled career intelligence officials
they were concerned the New York Times
reports about Kushner's business ties to
foreign governments they reported that
in May then White House chief of staff
John Kelly was ordered by the President
to grant Kushner top clearance both
Kelley and then White House Counsel done
began objected to the move pending
internal memos detailing their concerns
no I don't think I have the authority to
do that I'm not curated in an interview
with the New York Times last month the
president denied any involvement but I
wouldn't I wouldn't do it around the
same time the president's daughter an
adviser Ivanka Trump said her husband
received no special treatment there were
anonymous leaks about there being issues
but the president had no involvement
pertaining to my clearance or my
husband's clearance the president is
also saying he was misinterpreted
following backlash over his statement in
Vietnam about North Korean leader Kim
Jong Un's role in the treatment of
American otto warmbier he tells me that
he didn't know about it and I will take
him at his word the 22 year old college
students spent 17 months in North Korean
detention for alleged theft he was
returned to the u.s. in a coma and died
just days later won't be as parents
rebuked the president blaming the North
Korean dictator and his regime of
unimaginable cruelty and inhumanity for
the death of their son they wrote no
excuses or lavish praise can change that
now the White House faces a Monday
deadline by the House Oversight
Committee which is demanding those magan
and Kellee memos there's also an effort
brewing to obtain the president's tax
returns following his former fixer
Michael Cohen's testimony alleging
criminal acts by the president Anthony
Errol thanks very much